voilà monsieur bonsoir la croix rouge
française serait-elle devenue une
vieille dame indigne
depuis 125 ans son nom est synonyme de
bonnes oeuvres et de bénévolat
l'organisation a grossi elle emploie
maintenant treize mille salariés pour
cent mille bénévoles et un chiffre
d'affaires annuel de 2,4 milliards de
francs
la voici depuis une semaine soumise à
une double enquête de l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales et de
l'inspection des finances
comme le révèle le canard enchaîné la
raison officielle déficit financier
important
la crise s'est précipitée aujourd'hui le
président du conseil d'administration a
été démissionné
madame georgina dufoix l'ancien ministre
des affaires sociales le remplace l'
affaire dominique verdeilhan and gas
urgent un état d'urgence pour la croix
rouge française l'association caritative
vieille de 125 ans est aujourd'hui en
pleine hémorragie financière
elle accuse un déficit de près de 90
millions de francs malversation ou
mauvais gestion c'est pour l'instant le
secteur hospitalier de la croix rouge et
la direction de la croix rouge française
qui sont montrés du doigt par les
commissaires aux comptes
les dépenses engagées en octobre dernier
pour les cérémonies des 125 ans de la
croix rouge française aurait mis en
péril les équilibres budgétaires de
l'association une association qui gère
2000 unités conseils départementaux ou
comités locaux services d'éducation ou
services de santé tous dépendants
théorie d'une seule personnalité
juridique et d'une seule comptabilité
mais dans la pratique chaque unité peut
engager des dépenses sans l'aval de la
direction montant des ressources
annuelles de la croix-rouge plus de 2
milliards de francs
75 % proviennent des subventions
publiques et remboursements de la
sécurité sociale
25 % des dons legs du mécénat et du
sponsoring
ce sont donc plus de 500 millions de
francs qui sont adressés chaque année à
la croix rouge par des biens fait des
dons qui peuvent aussi être affectés à
des causes humanitaires ponctuelles et
bien déterminé le liban en guerre les
enfants du tiers monde
où le glissement de terrain en colombie
en 1985
personne n'a oublié le regarde omayra
l'élan de solidarité qui a suivi a
permis à la croix-rouge de recueillir 12
millions de francs la croix rouge
aujourd'hui accusé de n'avoir versé que
4 millions à la colombie où sont donc
passés les 8 autres millions
c'est vrai qu'il reste des fonds à
dépenser et pour l'utilisation de ces
fonds des pourparlers sont menées
activement avec nos partenaires que
vient de citer la croix-rouge de
colombier la ligue ce soir le départ de
louis d'auge à la présidence de la croix
rouge fait suite à plusieurs démissions
au sein de l'association
une information judiciaire pourrait être
ouverte dans les prochains jours le
parquet de nanterre et d'orge est déjà
en alerte